we did a poll beautiful poll perfect on  the david pakman show youtube channel  and the question was has your opinion of  joe biden  changed in light of his recent  accomplishments has it changed  71  of our audience  108 000 people voted think of that  number 108 000 of you voted 71 percent  said that yes your opinion has changed  in the direction of now approving of the  job that joe biden is doing  our audience is on the left our audience  is very liberal  but  what is clear  is that there is a momentum that is not  yet reflected in the polls  towards joe biden  and towards democrats that may really  surprise people on election day in just  a few weeks